[موسيقى]
انا بحلم
بتسوي هنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك في فندق الحمامه
انتم ايها البشر مساكين
[موسيقى]
عشان اكون واضح وصريح انا ما كان عندي
اهتمام
في الافلام من الصغر طيب انما كنت تجارب
يعني وانا صغير بقضي وقت في الشارع اكثر
من في البيت
فهذا اذا كان هذا له علاقه بهذا الفيلم
فهي ان انا شفت شخصيات كثير زين خصوصا
الفيلم في 2002 في حقبه مثير للاهتمام
بالنسبه لي لكن بعدين في الجامعه وانا
بدرس هندسه
اكتشفت هذا الجانب من ممارسه الفنون
في نادي المسرح يعني
فكانت تجربه جديده بالنسبه لي ان انا بخلف
شخصيات بخلق عالم
او ابروي في حكايه لكن يكون مستلهم من
الحياه الواقعيه شخصيات المثيره للاهتمام
الى اليوم انا الصراحه الحكايات او
الشخصيات
اللي فيها نوع من الغرابه
تثيرني وبالتفت لها وانا اعتقد ان الحياه
الواقعيه اغرب من الخيال احنا فاهمين ان
انك تصنع فيلم يكون
المنطقيه في
تماما زين كذا
مغلقه ان هذا هذا الواقع انما انت بتشوف
في الواقع انه بتصير قدامك يعني في شخصيات
بتشوف شخصيات متناقضه شخصيات تفعل شغلات
تبقى تحطها على المنطقه الصريح ما تزبط
شلون اسوي عمليه ممكن انها تفشل يلا تشيز
الغرابه اتوقع لان نوعيه الكوميديا او
السفره في الفيلم انا اسميها
الغرائبيه
فاتوقع ان هذا الستايل معين لانه يعني
الكوميديا مو لون واحد زينب فهذا واحد من
الوان
هذا الفيلم
خلينا نقول صوت المخرج فيه وصريح
فيبدو اني انا كذا بتعامل مع الاشياء زين
بطريقه ساخره
[موسيقى]
فبحب هذه النبره بحبها حتى في المشاهده
اتذكر اني لما كنت بشتغل على فيلمي الثاني
كان اسماء لسان اكتشفت اني مره كتير
بستمتع اني بروي حكايه فيها موضوع
بالناقشه وبننظر له وبنمر فيه يعني يكون
فيه انعكاسات لثقافتنا وحقيقتنا
كسعوديين لكن بهذا الموضوع الساخر تجاه
العالم اللي بنحكي فيه للحكايه او حتى
الشخصيات
خلونا لحالنا
[موسيقى]
الصراحه وانا بصنع الفيلم يعني ما كان
عندي هذا الاجابه طيب لان احنا في مرحله
يعني بدايه رهيبه وفتره ذهبيه الى اخره من
مسؤولياتنا نحن نصنع افلام متنوعه زين
وبنكتشف زين من ردود الفعل من الى اخره
وميزه الفيلم انه يبقى يعني سواء كان
اليوم
ذائقه بهذا الشكل قد اللي هو يرجع على
لكثير من الافلام التي تنتج خلال هذه
الفتره
لكن انا سعيد جدا انه في افلام
جمهوريه بشكل مباشر بحته جدا قاعده تزيد
من ثقه المشاهد المحلي لان هذه الخطوه
الاولى انت تبقى ثقه المشاعر المحلي ان
يروح بيشاهد الافلام ففعلا نحن في البدايه
نحتاج جميع الانواع محتاج الفيلم
السائد بالنمط السائد ونحتاج ايضا الفيلم
المختلف
وهذا الحال في جميع الدول يعني احنا اليوم
بنعرف كثير من المخرجين في امريكا مثلا
اللي بنعرف اسمائهم وكذا بس هي هدول
المخرجين
هم لهم فعلا قاعده جماهيريه لكن افلامهم
ما تعتبر كثير منها ما تعتبر ان هي
الافلام التجاريه البحته يعني هم مو هم
المخرجين يسوون مارفل
وفرنشايز الى اخره هم مخرجين لهم خلينا
نقول
دائقه معينه تحتاج انك تكون عندك عشان
تشاهدهم لكن نسبه الناس في امريكا اللي
يشاهدونهم كافيه انه يستمر اني اصنع فيلم
وهذا يعني اجلا عاجلا انا متاكد انه راح
يكون في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
طبعا انا بحب اني اشوف فيلم بشعر انه هو
محلي او بشعر انه في هذه النوع من الثقافه
والخصوصيه في العمل
لان بحس انه لما تشاهد فيلم
صادق زين لحقيقه المكان ولا الزمان زين
بتحس انه انت فعلا هو نقلك اذا كانك بتقرا
الادب
العربي والادب الروسي ولا تشعر ان هو جالس
ينقلك تفاصيل كثيره في المشاهده وفي
الاخير الانسان انت بتتعاطف معاه مهما
كانت
يعني
لان في في شغلات اساسيه مهما كانت قصه
مختلفه انت ما عشت زيها مو شرط تكون عشت
زيها لكن الكتابه والاخراج الجيد
بيحطك مكانها وبتشوف وبتحس بهمومها
والمصاعب بتواجهها
يلا تشيز